[Music]
squatters Are Taking Over America a
growing number of homeowners are being
tormented by people living freely in
houses they don't own and refusing to
leave Lawrence actually went to
Jacksonville Florida to meet with some
property owners who claim their home was
ravaged so we now came for the first
time in here to look at all of this what
was going through y'all's mind
you know your heart just drops and you
just wonder what kind of people can do
this I'm just curious if you guys
decided
we're just gonna barge it and take our
property back we would have been we
would have been arrested y'all would
have been arrested we've never told that
very clearly very clearly do not attempt
to remove them
but it's not just Jacksonville it's a
big problem in Philly where eviction can
cost thousands a legal expert there says
squatters appear to have the upper hand
and in Minneapolis a group of violence
Waters infiltrated in an apartment
building causing residents to fear for
their safety one person says she
suffered a broken bone when she tried to
stop a squatter from stealing her mail
we're sending out agents and they're
figuring out that their squatters in
these properties and it's hard getting
them out they've broken through a wall
they've broken a hole into the wall into
a storage room
right and I and they they're in there I
feel abandoned
um and I feel like I'm living in
um
in a garbage dump
[Music]
Lawrence uh tell us more about your
interviews I mean you'll see it on cross
country but I mean these people had a
fake lease cops knew it was fake but
they have no discretion anymore
um they printed out fake Pavements and
landlords and because of the legal
system they get 30 days the the
plaintiffs have to make a case in court
and in the meantime they're trash into
place and guess what after they've done
and they lose they get evicted and they
just move on to the next house
um it's not just Jacksonville it's
happened all across the country and it's
not just the people that are selling
their home say you want to go to
vacation for two weeks come back there's
a couple that have moved into your house
they decided to put pictures up make it
look like their house you call the cops
the cops they say hey look this is our
spot
You're Gonna Go not them so you got to
protect yourself make sure you have
cameras locks on your doors because
unfortunately until they change the laws
the cops can't come save you well
yep the cops can't come save you because
even if you say look I want to file a
trespass charge against these people the
cops maybe might consider it but at the
very least that identifies the first
date that you've complained of them
squatting on your property the cops are
most likely going to say this is a civil
case you got to go to landlord tenant
court or whatever it's called every
state has different rules for landlord
tenant there are certain states that are
very tenant friendly New York New Jersey
untenant uh tenant unfriendly
Pennsylvania and it goes on like that so
you could end up trying for a year to
get people out but there's one
interesting point in all of this uh and
first of all they can damage your
property and they can be worth nothing
and you so you sue them I mean you may
not even know who they are and you'll
never get a judgment or you'll never get
the Judgment paid the lien paid but
there's something called adverse
possession so when someone is living in
property and I learned this in law
school if it is open in continuous
exclusive adverse notorious ocean they
ultimately can gain title to that
property as though they own the property
and so people have to be careful you
have to be very on top of your own
property and know what the law is in
your jurisdiction because they could say
I've been there for five years I own
this place
well Jesse it's interesting because
obviously during the pandemic there were
all of these moratoriums on evictions
and it really changed the face of how
people are living and it seems now that
the system is just being completely
abused
correct there are three options on how
to handle a squatter option number one
you turn off all of the utilities so you
turn off the power and you turn off the
water
treat them like a rogue nation and you
might have a humanitarian crisis on your
hand but that's what you have to do it's
not going to work just in Afghanistan
this couple tried to do that then you go
to option number two legally you can
which is you out squat the squatter you
stake them out in the morning if they
leave then you go in with a notarized
lease or the deed and you get in and
then when they come back you say sorry
now I'm calling the cops and you have to
get out of here you can't do that either
you get charged with criminal trust
should not if you have a notarized
leaser
are not going to enforce it they don't
leave you go option number three which
is the legal route which is my least
preferred route and you might have to
take sometimes judge you're right it
could take eight months oh yeah for this
to be adjudicated because in some of
these jurisdictions they treat a tenant
and a squatter the same so good luck
um if you know an arsonist you can also
go that right I don't recommend that oh
my God I don't recommend that it goes
right now
chilling we like to clean that up a
little bit I would like to be invisible
you're on TV right now at least for the
next hour I was going to say you know
you mentioned the federal moratorium on
eviction so that ended and then also at
the same time there were federal and
state rental assistance programs all
those have now just expired in the
course of three months so that's why
you're seeing a proliferation of
squatters it's because all these people
who couldn't afford rent
but we're living rent free essentially
during the pandemic are now getting
kicked out on their bums and have
nowhere to go so they're invading other
people's homes I think that's why this
is going on so how you solve it I have
no idea but I will also I will also must
know arson right I think I spoke to this
property lawyer in Philly yesterday who
told me that in her State it's going to
cost you judge you can probably tell us
more about this but it's going to cost
fifty one hundred dollars just to start
legal proceedings if you want to fight
back against squatters Pennsylvania
is landlord friendly well she said 5100
that sounded like a lot of money to me
so that means in in like New York it's
probably even more expensive so how you
know like how are you going to be a
high-priced lawyer so I was gonna are
there any options if you don't have
thousands of dollars to go after these
people or you're just stuck you can go
to landlord tenant court you can you can
end up pilot yourself yeah you file it
yourself but there's usually a filing
fee what is the filing fee you no do you
get pro bono can you get you know legal
aid to help calendar and the time loss I
just got a celebrity I love the way
Jesse think you think like a Texan you
do but you're not going to be able to do
that burn them out and fill it you know
you can't do that I mean Texas would
cover our guns but that's another story
I was going to say please no shootouts
also at the squatting locations okay you
can catch more of that story on Lawrence
Jones cross country tomorrow night at 10
o'clock Eastern